Narrator: Tonight on the
season finale of "Shark Tank,"
Daniel Lubetzky,
the billionaire founder of Kind,
returns to the Tank.
You're, like, why America is
the amazing country it is.
Who wants to make
the world a better place?
I think
it's a phenomenal product.
What are your sales?
Loss, 200K.
‐Ohh!
‐Oh, wow.
Eventually, you got to
run a business!
And we are.
You've been in business
for seven years.
What's the product?!
I need a solution.
Like, God, please help me.
I want 33%
of the company...
Yowza!
...and I will give you
$1 million.
What?!
It's never happened before
in "Shark Tank" history.
Yay!      Yay!
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a solution
for one of the biggest issues
for babies.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Tara Williams,
and this is my husband,
Rob Williams,
and I'm here today
seeking $100,000
in exchange for
10% equity in my company,
Dreamland Baby.
Sharks, as a mom of four,
I know better than anyone
there isn't a sound in the world
worse than a crying baby.
[ Baby crying ]
[ Groans ]
With babies waking up
every few hours,
the amount of uninterrupted
sleep parents get...
[ Laughter ]
...can sometimes feel like
bare to none.
‐Ah!
‐And that is no way
to function through life.
But, Sharks, that's exactly
what we were doing.
When our son Luke was
nearly 6 months old,
he was still waking up
every hour and a half.
Oh, wow.
When I say nobody was sleeping,
I mean nobody.
Not me.
[ Chuckles ]
Definitely not me.
That is until I created this ‐‐
Dreamland Baby,
a weighted blanket sleep sack
designed to help your baby
feel calm, fall asleep faster,
and stay asleep longer.
The gentle weight increases
both serotonin and melatonin,
naturally reducing stress
and increasing relaxation
through deep touch stimulation.
The first night our son
wore his Dreamland Baby,
he went from waking up
every hour and a half
to sleeping 12 hours ‐‐
through the entire night.
It was an absolute
game changer for our family.
So, who wants to join me
and make that dream a reality?
Wow.
Do we have them?
You have samples
in front of you.
Herjavec: Oh.
Okay.
Robert and Lori,
you have a size small,
which is for
zero to 6 months.
And the other three gentlemen
have a medium, 6 to 12.
‐Oh!
‐Whoa.
Yeah.
I'm going to sleep.
Good night.
And yes, please say goodbye
so he can get
some real rest.
Greiner: Buh‐bye.
Good luck, Dad.
Sleep well.
So, the beads inside, they're
called poly pellet beads.
So, the same thing that's
inside of a beanie bag.
They're little beads
of plastic?
Yes, yes.
And they are completely safe.
They're non‐toxic,
they're food‐grade.
So, it's a sleep sack
with beads?
Correct.
And why is it better
than every other
sleep sack I've used?
And there are a lot of
sleep sacks on the market.
There are a lot
of sleep sacks.
And I know that you
have seen them
and used them
with your kids.
Well, with the beads, too?
None with beads.
I definitely love
heavy blankets.
Yeah.
I sleep much better
than when they're thin.
I've never heard of this.
Is there scientific research,
or it's just obvious to you,
and it's just your logic?
Yeah.
No. I mean,
first, as a mom ‐‐
I would love to share my story,
if I could start there.
Yes, please tell us
about you.
Please.
Please do.
So, the invention
of Dreamland Baby,
it started,
um, on March 29, 2018.
‐Uh‐huh.
‐Can you be more specific?
[ Chuckles ]
Well, this is why.
That was the day we had
a scheduled induction
for our son Luke.
Now, the day before,
my husband got laid off
from his job of 15 years,
so that was devastating for us.
Two months
into my maternity leave,
I was also laid off.
We were like, "Oh, my gosh.
What are we gonna do now?
We have four kids 5 and under,
we have no income...
‐Wow.
‐...and we have this baby
who's relentlessly waking up."
There was a day that
I was driving in the car,
and I nearly got
in a car accident.
I was with my four kids.
And I remember pulling over
and just tears streaming down
my eyes,
and I was crying, saying,
"I need a solution."
Like, "God, please help me."
That very night,
we had the older kids in bed,
and we had a heavy
throw blanket on our couch.
We laid it on top of Luke,
and I just saw this calm
immediately come over
his face.
A light bulb went off
in my head, and I thought,
"He needs a weighted blanket."
Yeah.
So I thought,
"Absolutely,
there must be one
for babies."
And I couldn't believe
there wasn't.
So, my mother‐in‐law sewed
our first prototype,
and then the first night
he wore it,
he slept for 12 hours.
Wow.
We thought,
"This has got to be a fluke."
But next night, 12 hours.
It was so immediate that ‐‐
So you know
this thing's working.
Absolutely. It was just,
"Oh, my gosh. Okay."
So it was a mother's intuition
combined with,
"Now there's got to be
science behind it."
So, my background,
I come from
the medical‐device space.
I've been there
over 10 years
in sales
and market‐development roles.
Oh, interesting.
So I speak and think
clinical trials.
There had been a clinical
trial that was published
in October of 2018,
so I've actually now partnered
with them,
and the woman who, um,
published the study
had actually helped me
with some early designs.
And so we know that it's safe.
Good for you.
Thank you.
Where did you get the money
to pay for this?
So ‐‐ [ Chuckles ]
When my husband and I
were both laid off,
we had no money coming in.
It was a desperate situation.
But when I was
on maternity leave,
in the State of California,
they pay you a stipend
for being on maternity leave.
So, I had $14,000 that wasn't
in our joint account.
It was in this other account.
So that's actually
the money I used to start it.
Don't say that out loud.
[ Laughs ]
I know. Shh!
Don't tell my husband.
You mean your husband
didn't know
you were spending
the $14,000?
That's why you asked
him to leave?
Well, he didn't really
know it was there,
'cause it was in
another account.
[ Laughter ]
So, yes, there was
an interesting conversation
when, all of a sudden, he said,
"What is this account?"
So, essentially, you took
the maternity‐leave money
from the company
that fired you
to start this business,
and, boom shakalaka, right?
Yeah.
Pretty much, yeah, so...
‐Shakalaka is right.
‐Boom shakalaka.
I used that first money
for the patent pending
and then also to
get prototypes made.
Where are you selling?
How much are you selling?
Yeah.
What do you
sell them for?
Okay, so, year to date,
we're at just about $30,000.
‐Ooh.
‐Ugh.
We did a ‐‐
That's not bad.
Go ahead.
We did a Kickstarter
the month of June,
raised about $25,000.
So, of that $30,000, $25,000
is from Kickstarter.
Was the Kickstarter.
And my website has been live
for three weeks.
How much do you
sell it for?
$79.
What does it cost you
to make?
The small is gonna be,
um, $13.60,
and the medium
is gonna be $12.20.
‐Cost?
‐Yeah.
This isn't a company yet.
It's a product.
Mm‐hmm.
You got a world of
challenge ahead here.
It's a great product
that's not investable yet.
Go make a model
that you can come to
an investor like me and say,
"Look, give me $1 million,
and I'll get $10 million
in sales."
That's interesting.
This is not interesting.
I'm sorry, I can't go on
the journey with you, Tara.
I'm out.
Alright, I ‐‐
Thank you for that.
I appreciate it.
Tara, um, you're, like,
an incredible inspiration.
Thank you.
You're, like,
why America
is the amazing
country it is.
Aww. Yeah.
Like, you're down
with your luck,
you and your husband both,
one after another,
lose your jobs.
You turned that around,
you turned a crisis
into an opportunity,
and you're building something
really, really compelling.
I don't think I'm the right
Shark to help you here.
I think there's people
that know far more than I
about the space,
so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay, thank you.
I appreciate it.
Yeah, Tara, I mean,
the fact that you
started when you did ‐‐
I started my first company
after I got fired, you know?
And when your back's
against the wall, you know,
if you have that
entrepreneurial spirit,
you always find a way.
Yeah.
And for this product,
it's a great
niche product, right?
I don't see this as being
a big enough business
for me to invest in.
So for those reasons,
I'm out, but congratulations.
I think it's
a phenomenal product.
Thank you. Yeah.
And so I think you're
gonna do just fine.
Thank you. I appreciate it.
Congrats.
Greiner: Listen, one of
the most important
but I think wonderful things
about our country
is one idea
can change your life.
Yeah.
So...
I feel that you've
done everything right,
but I know the road
you have to toe.
Absolutely.
Okay?
And I believe you can make it,
but I know the amount of work
that has to go into it...
Yeah.
...and it's a boatload.
But I'm gonna
make you an offer.
My thought is that it might be
extremely helpful for you
to license this to somebody
who is in the business
of either manufacturing
baby products
or in the baby arena.
So, um, really what I would
do is, say, $100,000,
but I would do it for...
uh...
I'd do it for 25%.
But my goal is to find you
a licensing deal.
I‐I‐I understand it.
I also just want
to be fair to Robert.
Robert?
Well, you know, as Daniel said,
I love your story.
I love how
you've gotten here.
I congratulate you.
I've been through
the crying babies,
and now they're these
amazing almost‐toddlers.
For me to put up with
a crying baby,
there's got to be
a great return.
‐Right.
‐Your business is at
the crying‐baby stage.
I'm not sure the return
is big enough right now
in the route
that you're going.
So I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Lori ‐‐
What do you want to do?
That is a great offer,
but I do have to counter.
I'm not liking you
as much anymore.
Oh, I'm liking you more.
I'm liking you more.
So, I would like to counter
for the same deal,
but at 20% instead of 25%.
Hmm.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
[ Sighs ]
Lori, do this deal
with me.
20% is huge.
That's great.
And together, I mean,
there's another company,
SleepSack,
that is on track to do
$90 million this year.
Tara, you must be
out of your mind.
No.
So that could be us.
What if we're on track
to do $90 million?
20% of $90 million?
That's a lot of money.
I don't think you
slept enough last night.
It's a great deal, Lori.
[ Laughs ]
It's a great deal.
I came here offering
a discount,
and you got double
what I'm asking?
You're winning.
It's a great deal.
Let's do this, Lori.
Tara, listen, I really did not
want to go under my 25%.
I thought that was fair.
I thought it was good.
Um, I will meet you
halfway.
I will go 22.5%.
♪♪
Let's do it.
Let's do a deal.
‐Okay!
‐Yay!
Yay. We're gonna have
sleeping babies.
And when we do
$90 million in three years,
we'll send some
out to you guys.
[ Laughs ] That's right.
That's right.
‐Good luck with that.
‐Congratulations, Tara.
Alright, guys, thank you.
Cuban: Thanks, Tara.
Congratulations.
♪♪
Can't believe I made a deal!
I feel amazing.
Lori is who I came here for.
And, you know, I have four kids,
I have two daughters,
and I'm just showing them
[voice breaking] that they can
do anything they want.
So, I'm so excited!
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a company
with a unique way
of doing business.
[ All shouting ]
[ Sharks laugh ]
Aaah!
[ Laughter ]
Hey, Sharks,
I'm Mohammed.
I'm also Mohammed.
And I'm Anthony, but you can
call me Mohammed, too.
We're from ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
We're from
Bloomington, Indiana ‐‐
Waaah!
Go Hoosiers! Yes.
...seeking $60,000
and marketing expertise
in exchange for 10%
of our business.
When you shower
with traditional soap,
you're actually slathering
animal fat all over your body.
[ Laughs ]
As Muslims who happen
to be vegans,
we don't eat meat
and hated the idea
of "cleaning" ourselves
with animal fat.
So that's why we created
our company, The Mad Optimist,
a totally unique,
different, radical,
customizable soap
and body‐care company.
Everything we make is
vegan, halal, non‐GMO,
gluten‐free,
and cruelty‐free.
Yay!      Yay!
[ Chuckles ]
Here's how it works.
You simply
go to our website
and choose the type of product
you'd like to make.
Let's say
you choose soap.
Then you pick your
essential‐oil scents.
Together:
[ Inhale deeply ] Ahh!
And you even get to pick
add‐ins, like spirulina,
coconut milk,
or activated charcoal.
And to continue the fun,
you can pick your
packaging design
and name your soap
anything you want.
And, Sharks, for the very first
time in "Shark Tank" history,
you're gonna hear something
you've never heard before.
We have
a sliding price scale.
[ Laughs ]
That's right!
A sliding price scale.
Where customers can choose
how much they pay
for their products.
So for customers who can afford
to pay a little bit more,
it offsets the cost
for customers who need to pay
a little bit less.
We are crazy about doing
good in this world.
We run our business
very differently,
and that's because everything
that we do is deeply rooted
in transparency,
integrity, and kindness.
So, Sharks, which
one of you is a...
Together: Mad optimist?!
[ Sharks laugh ]
So, we pre‐placed
customized gifts
for each of you in front of you.
‐Alright!
‐Oh, thank you. Thank you.
‐Yeah.
And each box has a custom soap,
custom lip balm,
custom bath soak,
and custom spray,
each designed just for you,
named for you.
This stuff
smells delicious.
Thank you.            Thank you.
Thank you.
Guys, this deal where
I design my own bar of soap,
I mean, are you
actually making
individual
soap bars for each order?
Can I smell yours,
Daniel?
‐Yeah, we are. Yes. Yep.
‐Yep.
‐Why?
‐To Kevin's point,
what are the economics?
Duncan: Sure.
Uh, so, soap is our
most popular product.
It's about 80% of what we've
sold so far with the custom.
The cost for that
is about $4.50 per bar,
and, uh, like we said,
it's a sliding scale.
So you can choose anywhere
from about $6 to about $16.
So, uh, $8.50 is the average,
and then ‐‐
You mean I can choose
how much I pay you for it?
‐Yep.
‐Yeah.
‐And we have a ‐‐
‐His brain is about to blow up.
So, you know, why we do that,
Mr. Wonderful, is we want ‐‐
Why?
We want everyone
to afford our body care.
Please help me understand
this madness.
See, we feel like
this is a premium product,
and we want everyone
to afford it.
You're averaging
the median?
You're in the middle,
right?
‐Absolutely.
‐Yeah. Yeah.
And what's your
profit margin in the middle?
So, the profit margin
in the middle is about 50%.
50%?
Anthony, how long have
you been doing it?
With The Mad Optimist brand,
it's been about 11 months.
Alright, the last 11 months,
what are your sales, and what ‐‐
So, last 11 months
with The Mad Optimist,
it's been about $21,000.
And I do want
to add in that ‐‐
[ Chuckles ]
$21,000?
That's it?
‐Don't laugh.
‐Well, that kind of reflects
our back end.
‐I'm trying to be optimistic.
I'm trying to be
optimistic.
No, no, no. Absolutely.
Sure, sure.
Mohammed A.:
Absolutely. Absolutely.
O'Leary: In 11 months,
you've sold $21,000?
Of custom soap.
And I do
want to add in ‐‐
What are
your total sales?
Our sales have been,
uh, $97,000 year to date.
Do you ever go home
at night and say,
"What is
the meaning of life?"
[ Laughter ]
Every night.
Every night, we do. We do.
It's a good question
to ask ourselves.
Guys, tell us
the evolution.
Yeah.
Right.
How you got here,
who you are.
There's been a bit of
a transition.
Yeah. Thank you, Mark.
Why?
Well, I guess at
the very beginning,
the three of us started selling
at farmers' markets,
shows, stores,
and throughout Indiana,
and then fast forward
five years, we ‐‐
‐Five years?
‐Yeah.
Herjavec: You did that
for five years?
Yeah, first few years ‐‐
How much soap did you sell
in that five years?
Uh, we sold ‐‐
So, it's $800,000
in total since the beginning.
And the beginning
was what year?
In five years?
Five years ‐‐
It's seven years now.
Mohammed A.: No, no, no.
Guys, what do you actually do?
What are your real jobs?
Well, this is our job,
and we've been working
really hard
to make it happen.
You don't have
any other job?
No.
Do you eat any protein?
[ Laughter ]
Do you eat anything?
How do you pay yourself?
We've used up some savings,
and then family's been
helping us out...
Mohammed A.: Yeah.
'cause everyone really believes
in what we're doing.
And the other question is
why are you optimistic?
[ Laughter ]
You have no reason
to be optimistic.
Half the time, they're mad,
half the time,
they're optimistic.
The definition of insanity
is doing the same thing
over and over again
and expecting
a different outcome.
But they already told you
they're insane.
O'Leary:
There's no growth.
You're hand‐making bars
and doing $21,000.
No, that's just the soap.
We also do
wholesale that ‐‐
Okay, look.
I‐I‐I tried
to be optimistic.
There is nothing here
for an investor.
And also your parents
must be asking
when you're gonna
wake up and get jobs.
I'm out.
Well, thank you
for your time.
Thank you
By the way, the energy that
oozes out of every one of you
and out of your
packaging is awesome.
‐Thank you, thank you.
‐There's so much
vibrant, beautiful energy.
But you have
a long ways to go.
You're way too obsessed
about your mission,
and you're not letting
the product shine through.
I think you have
a very long journey
to figure
a lot of stuff out.
Best of luck.
I'm out.
Greiner: I couldn't love
the three of you more.
You are fun,
you have purpose...
Thank you.
...and you are good to the core.
But this isn't the business.
I would be so in
because of you.
But because the business
isn't going to get you there,
I truly am pained
to say I'm out.
Mohammed plural, Anthony,
I really love your energy,
but I could not hate
your business more.
The open market does not
reward good intention.
It rewards results.
Three great guys
with a mad business.
I'm out.
You have to understand
how different we are.
We have our revenue numbers
live on our website.
You go to our website,
you place your order,
you'll see that
number increment.
You are so obsessed
with all the coolness
of running a business.
Eventually, you got to
run a business!
And we are. And we ‐‐
You've been in business
for seven years.
What's the product?!
Sell something!
Our product is
customized body care,
and ‐‐ which no one else is
doing out there.
Exactly, and you don't ‐‐ you
don't properly celebrate that.
You don't ‐‐
What matters is that
the world becomes
a better place to live.
The world cannot become
a better place to live
if you don't contribute to it.
♪♪
Narrator: Four Sharks are out,
and the Sharks are concerned
that Anthony, Mohammed,
and Mohammed are losing sight
of the business of their
mission‐based body‐care company,
The Mad Optimist.
Mohammed M.: What matters
is that the world
becomes a better place
to live.
The world cannot become
a better place to live
if you don't contribute to it.
We're not ‐‐
See ‐‐
We're not confused.
We have a plan.
We've done wholesale
and bulk custom.
You don't have a plan. You've
been doing it for seven years.
You pivot all the time.
Which is fine,
but you have no results.
Duncan:
We did one major pivot.
That's a hasty
generalization you made of us,
and that's not fair.
Custom is our
entryway.
This is our point of
differentiation.
No one is doing custom
bar soaps like we are.
So, what's next? What comes
after custom bar soap?
[ Sighs ]
So, I mean,
we already have
custom lip balms,
bath soaps.
We're adding on other
body care products, as well.
Would you be willing to have
multiple businesses?
In other words,
verticalizing?
So, when you first came in,
you started talking about,
you know, being Muslim,
and how, you know,
you have a different
orientation towards products.
Right?
Why not have a website
that focuses just
on that market?
Yes. Microsite.
Like a microsite. Yeah.
Yeah, microsite.
So, have you done that?
Um, not yet.
It's been one of our plans.
Cuban:
So, you would do it?
‐Yes.
‐Yeah.
Because ‐‐
Mark, if you give
these money ‐‐
Shut up, Kevin.
You give them money,
you're cursing them.
They're gonna stay
doing this.
[ Chuckles ]
This is horrible.
But what really caught
my attention
that I think
has not been done anywhere,
and you started to get
to this ‐‐
showing your revenues.
Yeah.
Right?
Having the slider on price
so people can pick
your pricing, right?
Absolutely.
Now, typically,
these guys are all right ‐‐
the mission can't
lead the way.
But sometimes when
a mission discloses
something unique
that's worth the effort,
then okay,
it's worth a flier,
particularly when
it's $60,000, right?
What's the unique
part here, Mark?
Sometimes it's just not
a good idea.
You ever thought of that?
No, and sometimes
it is a good idea.
I like the idea of being
totally transparent,
I like the idea
of having the slider,
pay what you can afford.
So, I'll make you the offer.
I'll give you the $60,000.
I'll help you with this,
but I want 25%.
Why don't you get 110%?
[ Chuckles ]
This is amazing.
Um...
No, I'm not gonna
negotiate.
Are you kidding?
You have nothing.
Uh‐‐ um...
That ‐‐
W‐We love the offer.
So, we all have
equal partnerships, even ‐‐
Now we all will.
Can you go down
to 18%?
No, it's got to be the 25%
because there's got to
be enough there where I ‐‐
[ Groans ]
Okay,
I'll go down to 20%,
and I'll let you guys
convince on the 2%.
Wow.
We would like
to do that.
However, there's one
contingency,
and that one contingency
is this is Ashura, and so...
‐Today is the day.
‐Basically, the first airing
of this episode,
we would like to donate,
uh, 100% of the proceeds
of this day.
That's your choice.
That's fine.
Okay.
Oh, well, then great!
Let's do it.
[ Laughter, cheering ]
Thanks, guys. Congratulations.
Appreciate it.
Thank you very much, Mark.
Thank you very much.
Alright.
‐Congrats, guys.
‐Anthony.
Thank you, Sharks.
[ Sighs ]
Whoo!
Oh, my gosh!
When they gave away
100% of the sales
on "Shark Tank" night...
Yep.
...their biggest night ever,
it will guarantee that
this business
never, ever, ever
makes any money.
So I think you've done
a horrible thing here.
You've left them
in a curse.
They're trapped in a business
that will never profit.
See, that's the difference
between you and I, Kevin.
No, I am right.
You are wrong.
He's gonna coach them.
I am the side of light.
You're on the side of darkness.
You've put them
into Hell.
See, Kevin ‐‐
Not only Hell.
No, that's not true.
The third level of Hell
where they make soap
one bar at a time.
Kevin, I have total
confidence in my ability
to make them successful.
I know you don't
have that ability.
I have plenty of ability,
but that business doesn't work.
By your logic, almost
none of us would be here.
No.
No, seven years!
The market has spoken!
Because by your logic,
we couldn't pivot!
It took me 10 years
in the wilderness
before I figured out ‐‐
But you were growing!
I am so not worried.
Greiner: The best thing in the
world to me as an entrepreneur
is that one idea can
truly change your life.
Cramsey: I came on "Shark Tank"
to make a difference.
I wasn't just representing
my family farm,
but family farms
all across America,
and now I have become
their voice.
Student debt is
really a national crisis.
Student loan debt
is affecting
over 44 million Americans
in this country.
It's our mission to
help future students
pay that debt off
as soon as possible.
You're now official licensees
of the National Football League.
O'Leary: Remember,
entrepreneurship is not
a destination ‐‐
it's a journey.
Narrator: We learned from
new guest Sharks
from all walks of life.
One of the secret ingredients
of America is our belief
in the entrepreneurial system
and the ability for us
to be able to foster this power.
Sharapova:
I like the attitude that
so many entrepreneurs have
that come on the show.
It's this "I won't give up
until I get what I want."
That is the American dream,
that there is no finish line
to what they do.
Lake: What I love about
entrepreneurship
is the optimism.
You're believing in something
that lots of people
don't believe in
and taking a point of view
that's not a common
point of view.
Wojcicki: My primary advice
for entrepreneurs
who are just starting out
is ride the ride, stick to it,
because you can overcome
almost anything.
Narrator: Our entrepreneurs
changed their lives
and the lives of others.
Heath: We wanted to have
an impact in the community,
but we had no idea
that it would turn into
the movement that it is today.
We've done over $225 million
in revenue
and donated over 30 million
pairs of socks to those in need.
Cheek: "Shark Tank"
put Everlywell on the map,
and now we're transforming
healthcare in America.
In just two years, we've done
$65 million in sales.
Goldman: Four years ago,
we were in a long audition line
for "Shark Tank,"
and we had no sales.
Today, we are dead set on being
a multibillion‐dollar company
that helps everyone
to get good sleep.
Together: To the good life!
We've now done $175 million
in sales since "Shark Tank."
Judy: A lot of times,
we look at each other and go,
"You know what?
This is the American dream."
And we are so grateful
for it.
Tran: You can create
your own destiny.
You can create
anything you want.
As painful as it's been,
I promise you
it's gonna pay off.
[ All chanting
"Shark Tank! Shark Tank!" ]
"Shark Tank" makes
dreams come true.
This is proof of it.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
are healthier
plant‐based versions
of favorite snacks.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
This is Ryan O. Cunningham,
chef and co‐founder
of RollinGreens.
People call him Chef Ko.
And this is my wife,
Lindsey Cunningham,
and she is our CEO
and co‐founder of RollinGreens.
We are from
Boulder, Colorado,
women‐owned,
and seeking $500,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in our company.
Sharks, right here
is an underutilized,
underrated ancient whole grain
called millet.
We've revolutionized
the classic tot
and created
a nutrient‐dense alternative
the whole family loves
and trusts.
And we're not just
stopping at millet.
We just launched
our cauliflower wings,
which are a direct
meat replacement.
And we have many
more products on the way,
which make the home chef
the hero.
This is not plant‐based food
made in a lab.
This is real food
from a real chef.
Food truck favorites
for our generation.
So, who wants to help
take the wheel with us
at RollinGreens
and lead the tasty,
clean‐food revolution?
Now let's eat.
‐Yay.
‐Yeah, let's try it.
Alright, guys, so excited
to feed you here today.
Sir.
‐Thank you, sir.
‐Thank you so much.
I'm giving you guys all a little
product box, as well, here.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Mr. Wonderful.
‐Thank you.
‐Sir. Enjoy.
"Finger‐lickin', no chicken."
‐Oh, yeah.
‐Exactly.
So, you have three tots.
You have our
OG original tots,
you have our
Italian herb, and then ‐‐
Herjavec: So,
this is the original.
It is, yep.
And that's dipped in
a little ketchup.
They're meant
to be dipped.
They hold crispy,
never get soggy.
Then we have wings.
So, spicy green buffalo.
Your sauces
are delicious.
Thank you. So, those were
our food truck favorites
that Ryan created
from our food truck days.
We did that for about
five and a half years.
Millet tots were
a top‐selling appetizer
on our food truck.
Wow.
Didn't exist
in the marketplace,
so we launched
with those.
Thank you, Lori.
They're the only
non‐potato whole‐grain tot
on the market.
This stuff is spectacular.
It's delicious.
Good. Thank you.
Thank you.
What does it cost?
So, $4.99 retail
for the millet tots,
and the wings, we just
launched four weeks ago.
Those are coming in
at around $6.99 a bag,
and they're flying
off the shelves.
And what does it
cost you to make?
So, about $1.70,
and we're selling them
right now for $3.11.
So, what are the sales
of the millet tots
over the last
three years?
So, most of our sales
to date are off one SKU,
which is our OG,
our original tot.
Last year, we ended the year
at $320,000 in sales.
On one SKU?
That was basically ‐‐
On one SKU.
And this year?
So, this year,
we're projected to
end the year around 700K.
Why do you think
you're gonna accelerate?
Because the commitments
we have going forward.
So, we just launched
in Super Targets
all over the country.
Kroger is our biggest
retailer to date.
Give me 2018 top line,
profit or loss 2018.
2018, 320K.
Okay.
Loss, 200K.
Yeah, I mean,
we're in high‐growth mode.
And what about 2019?
What about 2019?
2019,
we'll end around 700K,
and we'll probably
lose around 300.
‐Ooh.
‐2020, $5.5 million,
we have our revenue
projected to be.
What are you gonna do
with the money?
Because with the kind of losses
you're projecting,
you'll need the $500,000
just to stay in cash flow.
Yeah. Well ‐‐
So, are you planning
to raise this $500,000
and then raise more
in the next short term?
Yes, we are.
Okay, so tell us about that.
So, the use of funds
for this round
are really, number one,
to support our retail growth.
You know,
launching in Target...
Right.
...and all these
big‐box retailers, it's costly.
But ultimately, we don't want to
just have frozen products.
We see ourselves in
shelf‐stable and refrigerated.
So, about 30 products
over the next three years.
How much
are you gonna raise?
About $2 million.
Your food is delicious.
‐Thank you.
When things are tasty,
people come.
I'm not intimidated
by your business.
Look,
my Bantam Bagels came in
with one little
stuffed bagel ball.
Yep.
So there is some
sympatico here.
But I also would like
to have a partner here
in my fellow Shark, Daniel.
You're being so mean.
Lori, I can't do this.
I'm not being mean.
Well, I mean, your
whole philosophy is clean food
for the next generation.
This is exactly
what we're doing.
I'd love to help
you guys out,
but I can't save
every venture.
It's gonna take ‐‐
And that's okay.
It's, like, we've been
through the challenges
and we've sustained,
and that's who we are.
We execute.
I'm a little pistol.
He's Chef Ko.
But, no, you need
to be more focused.
You can't do everything.
You seem to say
you're listening.
Sir, I almost disagree.
We are so laser‐focused
that we just launched
our cauliflower wings.
We've been three years,
tots, demos, every day.
Yeah.
You keep on making a point,
and you don't take
your own advice, right?
You keep on coming up
with these options on expansion
that are just gonna consume
more cash.
Well, we're also
switching gears.
So, food service,
where the margin's better.
There you go!
That's exactly the point!
Food service
is gonna kill you.
You understand how hard it is
to get into food service?
Yes!
That worries me,
I have to say.
I mean, Daniel,
I appreciate ‐‐
Lindsey, please do not go
into food service yet.
We just landed
a huge account.
Just 'cause you land an account
doesn't mean it's good.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
What's your wholesale
price for the tots?
$3.11.
Okay, so, what's
your margin on the ‐‐
So, right now,
that's around 35%.
Alright, guys, I'm out.
[ Laughs ]
‐Mark, come back in.
‐Aw!
I'm out.
Thank you, Mark.
I appreciate you, man.
The bottom line is
the business model doesn't work
because your margins
have to be...
Cuban: A lot higher.
...close to 50%
to break even.
Yeah.
I see clouds.
You see clouds?
What kind of clouds?
I see clouds.
I see some bad things
are gonna happen to you.
No ‐‐
Mr. Wonderful!
I'm out.
Oh‐ho‐ho!
Thank you.
That's ‐‐ Aw.
No way. Are we hav‐‐
You said, "No, thank you"?
I'm sorry. Look, I got
to tell you the truth.
You're out? What do you think
bad's gonna happen?
I think you're gonna
go out of business.
‐Hmm.
‐That's what I think.
Lindsey, I am so tired
of everybody beating you up
up here for
the opportunity.
I get it.
You're all over the map.
You've got to slow down
a little bit.
‐Yep. Yep.
‐But they taste great.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
I have done really well
in 11 years on this show
by investing in great people.
You guys are great people.
I believe the mission.
It's the stuff in between
I'm stuck with.
Yeah.
I'll give you
the $500,000 for 20%.
Oh, if you don't say yes,
you're crazy.
Will you come back in to ‐‐
No!
No, stop.
Will you two
come in together?
There's nothing
wrong with that.
[ Laughter ]
You're absolutely right.
There's nothing
wrong with that.
You'll have to lose
the deal.
You two are masterminds.
‐Wow.
‐You can ask whatever you want.
I can offer ‐‐
Not if he's gonna stay in.
You had nothing,
and I made you an offer,
and now you want
another Shark in?
Okay, Robert,
how do you think ‐‐
Lindsey, if you don't want me
in the deal,
I'm happy to ‐‐
No, of course I want you
in the deal.
We love you.
But your answer was you
want me to bring Lori in.
♪♪
Let's do it.
Oh, my God,
are we serious?
Yeah,
let's come on now.
Alright, Robert.
So, can we do
the Phone‐A‐Friend?
But I'm ready.
I'm ready.
I'm ready, too!
Are you ready?
We have no friends!
Then what are we waiting for?!
Let's do it!
You have a deal.
Yes!
Whoo‐hoo!
[ Laughter ]
Alright!
We love you, man.
Thanks for being there.
Oh, yes.
Thank you, thank you,
thank you.
Wow.
That was awesome.
My God. Robert.
That was great. Good job.
You rocked it.
Congratulations, guys.
‐Whoo‐hoo!
‐Whoo!
Whoo!
What?! Whoo!
A moment of silence for that
money you just murdered.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is
a stylish way to relax.
♪♪
Hi, I'm Rachel, and I'm
the Chief Enthusiasm Officer.
Herjavec: [ Chuckles ]
And I'm Joe,
and I'm the Chief
Relaxation Officer.
We're seeking $400,000 in
exchange for 7% of our company.
Wow.
Between the e‐mails
popping up in your inbox,
24‐hour news blaring
from every screen...
[ Sighs ]
...and constant pinging
interruptions...
[ Sighs ]
...from your smartphone,
we're all feeling
more overwhelmed
and stressed out
than ever.
[ Sighs ]
We're all sick of feeling busy,
hectic, and rushed,
and our solution
to this frustration
is not another app
or gadget.
Our solution is the world's most
ridiculously comfy hammock.
[ Chuckles ]
Introducing
Yellow Leaf Hammocks.
As Yellow Leaf Hammocks,
we've perfected the hammock
for the modern consumer.
We've conquered
every obstacle,
from creating a cocoon‐like,
no‐wobble design
to a shockingly soft yarn
so you won't get a rope burn
when you're trying to relax.
And they're completely
weather safe.
Now we're breaking
the boundaries of relaxation
with our new invention,
the hammock throne.
Wow.
The hammock throne is
an indoor‐outdoor hammock chair
that makes it possible
to relax absolutely anywhere.
With the hammock throne,
you have a gorgeous
piece of furniture
that you can put out
in your living room,
on your tiny balcony,
or even in your office.
It extends back to create
a full‐length hammock,
large enough
for a 7‐foot person,
all within a diameter
of just 3 1/2 feet.
Wow!
And it swivels 360 degrees
so you can angle it...
Oh, that's cool.
...to gaze out the window
or relax while you watch
"Shark Tank."
[ Chuckles ]
First, we perfected
the hammock.
Now we've brought it
into your living room.
So, Sharks, who wants
to make the world a better place
and join us in our quest
to build a relaxation empire?
So, on the tables
in front of you
are specially selected
hammocks...
Oh.
...if you
open these up.
And first thing,
you want to look at the label.
They're all signed
by the women who made it.
We're a social
enterprise.
Cuban: I like that.
Yeah, they're all ‐‐
Herjavec:
Where do you make them?
We work with moms
in rural Thailand
to create
high‐wage jobs.
What do they cost?
What do you sell them for?
The ones that
we just gave you guys
are our classic double.
It's our
top‐selling size.
They retail for $199.
‐Ooh.
‐That's not bad.
Our current line ranges
between $149 and $299.
The $199 hammock,
how much do you pay for it?
$44 is our landed cost.
So, what is an average
hammock made out of?
Something like this,
what does that cost?
You can find a hammock
for $30 on Amazon,
to be perfectly
honest.
You could also find it
for $400, you know?
It's not gonna
feel like this,
it's not gonna
look like this.
And, Rachel, how much
is the contraption?
So, this is the brand‐new
hammock throne.
This is our high‐end
hanging solution
that we've just
introduced.
That's your product?
This is the first of many.
You made this?
Demin:
Yeah, we designed it.
Yeah, we did!
[ Laughs ]
So, this one is somewhere in
the neighborhood of $2,200.
‐Yeah.
‐Whoa!
‐Wow.
But it's an indoor piece
of furniture.
See, that seems like a lot.
Tell us the story
of how you got started,
why you're here.
Connors: Yeah!
Our inspiration
to start this
was to literally end poverty
in really vulnerable communities
in the developing world.
The idea for the company
started when I initially
went on a backpacking trip
across southeast Asia.
Without me.
Aw!
[ Laughs ]
We were living together
in Boston at the time.
And I stumbled across
a hammock on a remote island,
and I was immediately struck
by how soft it was.
I was really impressed
with the quality,
and I started asking
them some questions
and learned that it was woven
by this hill tribe community.
It was part of
an economic development program
to help this hill tribe
group out of poverty,
and I was really struck
by that.
In Thailand?
In Thailand.
In Thailand, yeah.
So, I went to this community,
and I got to meet
the actual weavers
and hear their stories,
and I learned
that this community
that started
making the hammocks,
with the help
of an aid worker,
had been previously
in debt slavery,
and the thing
that really struck me
was a lot of people
kept coming to this community
asking to join
the program,
but they were being
turned away
because there weren't
enough sales.
And I thought, "Well, we can
start a little hammock company
and provide enough jobs
in this region."
So I came home with a backpack
stuffed full of hammocks,
and I came home to Rachel.
I was thrilled that
my boyfriend...
[ Laughs ]
...wanted to quit
his finance job
and start a hammock company,
as you can imagine.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
I was literally ‐‐
"Yeah, honey, great idea!"
[ Chuckles ]
What are your sales?
This year, we're gonna
hit $1.3 million.
Wow.
Last year,
we did $860,000.
Your sales are
primarily online?
It's about 50/50 between
a combination of
direct‐to‐consumer sales
through our website,
as well as
strategic partnerships.
A big part
of our early wholesale
was kind of scattershot
patio stores.
We took a step back
from that
to focus on
strategic partnerships.
Who?
It's Virgin Voyages,
which is Virgin's
new cruise line business.
Yep. So, Virgin Voyages
will be putting
Yellow Leaf Hammocks in
every single balcony
of every single cabin.
What price do you get
from them for these?
They pay
our wholesale price,
but they'll also be,
um, retailing them.
So we'll be on
the room service menus
in the cabin
and on the stores.
The retail store
is projected
to more than double
our current business.
So, you've got to be
profitable then, right?
Last year,
on $860,000 in revenue,
our net income
was $110,000.
‐That's great.
‐After paying yourself?
After paying
ourselves, yeah.
Joe and Rachel...
Yes?
...here is my offer.
Herjavec: Bam!
Out of the five Sharks here,
I probably have
the most credentials
about building socially
impactful businesses.
So I understand
the challenges you're facing.
I really love a lot
of what you stand for,
but you have
$100,000 profit
with a crazy
$5.7 million valuation.
So my offer is as follows,
and it's an explosive offer.
I want 33%
of the company...
Yowza!
...and I'll give you
$1 million.
What?!
Wow.
Say yes or no,
and then it's done.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in.
Rachel and Joe
are seeking $400,000
for a 7% stake in their
mission‐based hammock company,
Yellow Leaf Hammocks.
Daniel is interested
and has made a staggering offer.
What?!
I want 33%
of the company...
O'Leary: Yowza!
...and I'll give you
$1 million.
Herjavec: What?!
Say yes or no,
and then it's done.
O'Leary: Whoa!
$1 million, 33%.
Demin: We ‐‐ The reason ‐‐
Connors: Wait. Actually ‐‐
Can I explain to you
the reasoning that ‐‐
Demin: You ‐‐
You mentioned our profitability
on last year.
I want to mention our
profitability on this year
and what we're doing next year,
to be fair to us.
Yeah, but that's a little
wishful thinking, right?
And I think you wo‐‐
No, 'cause they got
the order.
Go ahead.
Connors: Yeah.
So, on the $1.3 million
that we're doing this year,
we're doing
$360,000 in profit.
One of the biggest things
that we're looking to do
with this money
is we have a huge
product road map of solutions.
Rachel, stop talking
and take the deal!
So we started here.
He's paying you
over eight times ‐‐
Why? There might
be another deal.
Cuban: Good for you.
That's an amazing offer.
We also recognize
that we might not need
all of that money right now.
Oh!
No!
Well, we also might not ‐‐
What are you doing?
Well, we might not ‐‐
O'Leary: Oh!
Alright, well, hey,
if you don't need all
the money right now...
Good for you, Joe.
Good for you.
...I'm gonna make you an offer.
Want to hear my offer?
We don't ‐‐ We're not
prepared to give away
that much of our company.
[ Sharks groaning ]
Greiner:
Do you want to hear my offer?
‐Listen to Lori.
‐Alright.
Ohh.
Oh!
I mean,
I sit here, I listen.
‐Oh!
‐I watch ‐‐
It's a hammock company!
Demin: It's not enough.
Well, listen, he just said
maybe he doesn't need
all that much money.
So I will give you an offer.
I'll go $400,000 for 20%.
[ Chuckles ]
Now, granted,
his might be a better
offer for you.
$1 million for the 25%
and both of you.
I don't want to go
to the million.
How about
$500,000 for 25%?
No.
No, that dilutes ‐‐
Lubetzky:
What is your counter?
For 25%?
$600,000 for 14%.
Oh, wow.
Ugh!
Herjavec: I love the idea,
and I think you guys
are the real deal.
Thank you.
I will give you
the $400,000 for 15%.
Lubetzky: If you take
the million dollars from me,
you won't need to dilute
yourselves again.
You might.
You know how much money
Kind has raised
in its entire lifetime
for the business?
The total we ever raised
in our entire history
was $5.2 million, and we sell
over $1 billion in sales.
I'll teach you,
and I'll help you
run the business
in an efficient way.
Are you okay with 33%,
or is that too much for you?
I think it's too much
because ‐‐
What's the maximum
that you're willing to do
for someone that's gonna
really roll up their sleeves
and help you?
We're looking
at the future.
If you took 33% now,
I worry that we would ‐‐
it would hurt us at
a subsequent round when we grow.
Why?
What subsequent round?
Greiner:
When I started my business,
started with one product,
I took out a bank loan,
it was about $325,000.
I paid it back within a year,
and I never had to take a loan
or bring in
an investor again.
So listen, I don't think
you need to just sit there
and take on
all these investors
and take in
a whole ton of money.
You just need to be
strategically smart
and take in
the right investor.
But you need somebody.
That's the bottom line.
So I'm gonna
change my offer.
My offer is this ‐‐
I'm gonna go $200,000 flat,
then I'm gonna give you
a loan of $200,000 at 7%,
I'm going to fund purchase
orders if you need them,
and I'm going to ask for 17%.
I just offered you
$400,000 for 15% first.
You may not like it,
you may not,
but the one thing
that I can offer is,
is I can offer somebody
who will hold your hand,
take you down the road,
do everything that you need.
Lori.
I care about helping women,
I care about
helping environment,
I care about helping the world,
and I really like
the two of you,
so I care about helping you.
I love
the two of you.
Lori, thank you so much.
Love you guys.
We love you guys.
We're making it
hard on them.
What's the minimum
percentage,
and what dollar
do you want?
Yeah.
Focus, Joe.
Would you do...?
[ Chuckles ]
[ Whispering indistinctly ]
Would you do
$1 million for 25%?
♪♪
Just because I love you.
Yes!
[ Lori laughs ]
We're gonna make a huge
difference in the world.
Mm!
[ Laughs ]
We're gonna change
some lives.
I never thought
he'd go down to that.
It's never happened before
in "Shark Tank" history
when someone came in here
for $400,000
and walked out
with a million.
I'm really excited
to work with you.
We're gonna make
a huge difference.
I'm so thrilled.
Thank you.
Congrats! Good deal.
That's an
expensive hammock.
♪♪
I hope Daniel saw that we have
as much passion as he does.
We want to build this
not just for ourselves
and not just for our customers,
but for the people
that make our products.
And we want to create
a transformative brand,
and he's gonna be the perfect
partner to create that.
♪♪